those of you that are sitting on an
adjustable-rate mortgage where the flip
do you think it's going to adjust from
here do you think they're going to start
paying you I mean really why you would
have an adjustable rate mortgage in the
lowest interest rates in a hundred years
or 50 years anyway is beyond me those of
you sitting on a balloon mortgage are
you waiting on it to pop this is the
time to refinance we get lulled to sleep
by these low interest rates that have
been low for many many years now and I'm
old I've seen interest rates jump based
on geopolitical events I've seen
interest rates jump based on a president
doing something or not doing something
when they should and jump suddenly I'm
not predicting that I don't know I hope
that doesn't happen it would destabilize
and slow down the growth in the economy
I would not be a good thing I wouldn't
like it but if I were sitting on a
mortgage right now personally which
thank God I'm not and the rate was 4% or
higher or it was an adjustable rate or
it was a balloon rate I would be
refinancing it by the end of the week
three freaking percent really seriously
I got my real estate license in 1978
September three weeks after I turned 18
years old a week after I got my license
mortgage interest rates in 1978 went
from nine and three-quarters to ten the
wailing and gnashing of teeth that
mortgage interest rates were
double-digit 10% interest rates oh my
god that's what happened I remember
distinctly I was 18 years old was 40
years ago that's what the
sounded like it proceeded to go from 10%
on up to 18% for mortgage interest rates
any of you old enough to remember Jimmy
Carter being the president yep that was
a joyful time not seventeen and a half
percent Fannie Mae fixed-rate 30-year
mortgages by the way if you didn't know
in those days there were no adjustable
rate mortgages in those days there were
fixed rate mortgages 98% of loans were
fixed-rate 30-year mortgages period some
people took out 15s FHA loans in those
days were fully assumable meaning that
you didn't have to qualify to assume the
loan if you wanted to just hand your FHA
loan to somebody they could just come in
and start taking over the payments and
you just walked away you don't have to
qualify so you didn't you know you could
have a bankruptcy and the next day you
could buy a house on and assume someone
else's FHA loan back in those days
that's all gone now adjustable rates
came about because mortgage because of a
thing called disintermediation where the
savings and loans were put we're
borrowing money from the public meaning
their savings accounts rates were twelve
percent but they had a lot of mortgages
on the books that were only paying seven
percent they don't like to pay out
twelve percent and receive seven in the
banking world they like it to be the
other way around they like to pay out
seven or four or two or one and receive
from you much more than that when it's
upside down it's called
disintermediation the banking world got
upside down that's one of the reasons
SNL's no longer exists was that crash to
them that's why they came up with
adjustable rate mortgages so that the
next time mortgage interest rates went
up they wouldn't get caught the mortgage
the adjustable rate mortgage was
designed for the bank not for you
darling it was to protect them from
disintermediation that's why they came
up with it just in case you're wondering
in history on this stuff so this is how
I remember things it went from 18 by the
time I got married and was selling real
estate in my early 20s rates had come
back down we could we had fixed rates
for 14 and we had these new adjustable
rate mortgages for
and a half this is who you're listening
to i sold real estate in that world and
then everybody sitting around going I
don't know if they read a new briefing
it's a 3% interest you're kidding me
3% I mean that's not even the sweat off
of 14% seriously so I'm not making fun
of our last caller I'm just saying a
bunch of you need to get on the phone to
Churchill mortgage like what are you
waiting on and get your refinance done
because over the scope of time these
interest rates have been ridiculously
low for a long time and about the only
thing we know about life is its gonna
change so you should protect yourself by
getting the lowest possible interest
rate locked in until you get your own
paid off hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]